is
they could be i don't know they are
dressed
is
oh
uh
um
it's
open
there we go
technology
we're going to open up the
final
meeting of the committee
on ways and means
and we have to discuss
what we want to do with five interim
study bills
and some study bills at house bill 504
we can make one or two
choices
after we listen to discussion we can
not to consider for future legislation
or recommend future legislation or not
recommend
those are only only two choices so we're
going to start off with
house bill 504
which is the has to do with education
funding
thank you
is that on yeah it is
um
so yes we we're here to
decide what to do with what
recommendation to put forward on house
and i
i handed i i
took around
two pieces of uh
two two items one is a
document that you've seen before when we
decided to go as a committee to go into
interim study this was a document that
identify what was in the bill
and then
the second piece of the second article
uh is uh
is just two pages it's an excerpt only
from a complaint that was filed
i think it was late this summer
called rand v v the state of new
hampshire i'll say a few words about
that in a moment
but what i wanted to to say this is all
very brief because uh
is that
the core elements of this bill
are
what i want to focus on
and the first is
relates to what
it is not and what it does not do
it
it does not do away with swept
it leaves the tax in place
that's uh one fundamental point
the tax rate is unaffected by this bill
whatever the tax rate may be is a
product of how much money
the state determines should be
raised by the tax and currently
in this year it's about 263 million
uh starting fiscal year the next fiscal
year it will
be
363 million dollars
and then the rate uh that
is needed to produce that amount of
money is determined by dra
for my community
it plays out to a dollar and 87 cents
this year
uh it differs from community to
community because of the process of
equalization of
assessed values
so it does not do away with swept but it
does respond to a constitutional
challenge
that many people are fearful will be
brought it has been brought
in this complaint in fact and i will uh
go to that in a sec
but uh
the uh the bill itself requires that all
revenues produced by this tax
are sent forward by the
collecting agencies the municipalities
to the state for deposit in the
education fund
except for a an amount that may be
retained
by the municipalities to cover
essentially the costs of collection and
to encourage
outreach to
make the
rebate program for
for poor taxpayer taxpayers that have
limited resources
more effective
so it has
both that
element of all revenues go to the state
and then the second element allowing for
a retention of a small amount to cover
costs
of collection and
as an incentive
for the rebate program
and then thirdly most of central
importance it greatly enlarges
the
low and moderate income homeowners
income
uh property tax relief program
and
the most significant aspect of what's in
this bill is that it extends
the rebate to the school tax
as well as to the statewide property tax
once it does that that's as a big jump
in what
the relief will amount to
in my community
the school rate is about about twelve
dollars per thousand
and you add that to that the state
property tax rate 1.73
and you apply that to what in this bill
will become the uh
the top uh assessed value that can be
subject to the re relief which
in this bill is 220 000
and you get a fair amount of money
the bill caps what can be rebated at 1
dollars right now
and it also caps the total amount that
can be rebated across this
state at 25 million dollars
um both of those figures of course could
and finally
and there's the other last of the core
elements of this bill that i wanted to
highlight
it sets up a study
to explore ways of extending the
taxpayer relief
to tenants to renters
as it stands right now it's for
homeowners and we all know that tenants
uh through their rent are paying
significantly making significant
payments as a result of high property
taxes
and so back to uh this handout the
complaint
this was filed this summer it relates to
the larger issue of
fairness in school funding
and it's
referred to as the rand
case
rand v state of new hampshire
if you look on the
second page which is really the ninth
page of the complaint
there is a section five
uh headline the current education
property tax system is
unconstitutional
and it goes through i'm not going to go
through the details of it but basically
it's that there's a rebate essentially
the current tax is allowed to sit
uh as collected in the community in
which it's collected regardless of what
the
adequacy education
costs may be and for many
i won't say many for a significant
number of property wealthy
towns that means that they keep
more than they need for adequacy and
it's that aspect of
disproportionate
retention
that
triggers the constitutional concerns
which to this committee were raised in
the first instance by
william william artinger
a expert in tax matters that who's well
known
and
he submitted a letter which should be in
the record of this
this legislation
um
[Music]
stating
in forceful terms his opinion
that this tax because of this
disproportional aspect of
retention
is
unconstitutional
so
this
house bill 504 seeks to correct that
so i think what i want to say and sum up
is that
this is a matter that i think
indisputably
requires further legislation exactly
what that legislation would be
uh
would be to be determined it's not the
purpose of
an interim study to
come down hard on one side or another of
what
will be done but
but
this this question of constitutionality
needs to be addressed
the sufficiency of the taxpayer relief
program and the opportunity that swept
presents for a
broader tax relief program applying to
all the property taxpayers regardless of
whether it's
it's the state tax or the
municipal or school tax
local school tax
this kind of relief is desperately
needed we all know that
and uh future legislation can address
this
in a way that seems uh most suitable to
whoever files i expect that i would file
if i'm re-elected of course
um
and uh seek something similar to what
you have in front of you but it might
not be exactly the same so i hope that
uh for all of these reasons um
that we can agree that uh further
legislation is needed and
this subject and
go forward with that thank you
thank you for your comprehensive
analysis of this legislation
representative ames
and you bring up a point that i've
always agreed on
is the statewide education property tax
should have been delivered directly to
the state
and not retained locally
and
then i would knew what it was supposed
to do
okay
further questions or comments
representing early
thank you mr chair um
directed to representative ames
um
i was
generally under the impression
that the equitable and proportional
section
of tax law applied to the application of
the tax
not the distribution of the tax just for
my own education could you address that
represents
not sure i can do that distinction that
way but the uh
the um
tax as it's applied and in truth is
every every taxpayer is going to pay a
dollar
and something
um
used to be two dollars and something but
because of inflation and property values
it's gone down and it's the constant
amount to be collected has stayed the
same
um
[Music]
and then um
the
i believe there's some supreme court
language also to this effect
that um
if
the collected amount is then turned back
into the community so into one community
but not all
in a disproportionate way
so that in fact the taxpayers
in that community
that get back some of the state money
that's been collected
because that's what it is is state money
is not the localities money
if it comes back
to
effectively reduce the rate
that the property taxpayer is paying and
you know you and i can go back and forth
on
application versus rebate or whatever
and uh so what you know it's the court
ultimately that we'll figure this out
and uh i think everybody including
such an expert as mr
artinger backs off in terms of absolutes
and
recognizes that uh you know the final
call is going to be by the group of
represent you early and yes i think
you're correct on that and uh
because what it'll do is provide us if
this case goes forward and if it rules
the way that it looks like it probably
should rule it would give both this
committee the its sister committee in
the in the senate and dra guidance
regarding both
the taking of the tax and the
distribution of the tax and take that
equitable proportional
phraseology and apply it to both which i
think is an important uh thing that in
today's society needs to be done thank
you sir thank you and i agree with that
uh we often agree don't we
for representative romney
yeah i got a question a question for uh
brooks and vaynes
um
what's your sense in terms of the speed
of this case
i guess they have to i know things don't
move very quickly
yeah i'm just trying to get a sense of
you know i guess some of the judgments
of the of the court are going to be
taken into consideration
in our work i i'm not object i have no
objection to
to moving this
forward as a yes
for future legislation because i think
there's components as representative
major said that are i think i think we
can all agree on
i mean some of the details in this
current bill we may not agree on but i
think there's some things that we can we
can come together on
so
any sense if the case is going to give
this a priority or not or
you may not know
well i think that it's a it's the
question we all ask and wonder about and
uh there is a second school funding case
as you know
uh that began with the convale conval
school district complaining about the
inadequacy of the adequacy
grants that they're receiving and
and that was filed what a couple of
years ago i'm guessing
and life goes on and
and they're still in discovery and uh
now the second case has come along and
uh
whether that will slow things down or
speed things up i don't know
um i think it's going to be uh
i don't even want to venture i guess you
know i'm sorry but uh it's going to be a
while i kind of thought that would be
the answer but i just couldn't just ask
him the question thank you
for other questions or comments i'm
representing
thank you on i just wanted to provide a
little bit of um bill court history on
this
on which you know uh
that
the
we spent a number of years
after the first
on education funding task force that we
were both on
on
the legislature did
trying to
make the system that we'd
been stuck with work
and
on
we
changed the formula
and the
and the procedures and
the
supreme court for the first time
agreed that we had done enough
and that they were removing the strict
scrutiny that they'd put on us
on
that was changed mostly from the
initiative of the senate
to
undo
a number of those things one of them was
to make
the amount in the statewide property tax
363 million forever
um
and
the other
was to
allow
the uh donor communities as they were
called and are still calling themselves
sometimes
on to retain
the excess property tax that was raised
by this fairly small amount by the way
when we started it was
six
uh thousand
dollar
six hundred and six point six percent oh
six six dollars and sixty cents per
thousand
uh and it rapidly went down to i think
four
uh something like that and then
decreased again in in eleven
um and so
the only way because they dismiss
strict scrutiny the only way that that
this could be challenged again was to
start from something like this and
something like convol
and go back through the courts and the
courts can
delay things as they will depending on
uh have done so i think in the convol
case um but
uh it was
in
1996 december i believe after the
election that
we were
told by the supreme court that we had to
solve this now
and
and um
or maybe it was 98 98 98 yes
so um
we came in as second termer's first time
on the finance committee and they had to
put together a task force
and speaker scitec
uh
did a very brave
thing and uh opened up at that point in
late december
she opened up
the bill filings to allow anybody to put
in anything that they thought would
sufficient amount of money
to fund this we had a 1 billion a year
budget at that point for the general
fund there was no education trust fund
and uh
when we finished scraping away at
anything that might possibly not be
relevant
we were at 800 million
that we had to add
to the state budget so that gives you an
idea of
the huge jump that the courts required
and that the legislature decided it had
to react to
and i'm telling you all this because
nobody
tried to file and go through the long
case until a few years ago and
we may find ourselves this december
uh faced with the same conundrum whoever
is in charge whoever however many of us
are back
and um
it's it's going to be interesting and we
will need vehicles
and so i definitely support this because
it's
it's a
vehicle that can be used by whoever
is
trying to deal with the court
requirements
just to add a little bit of history to
this
in 1998
when representing alani and i were in
our second term
were both on finance
and at that time finance and ways and
mains was together
and there was normally three divisions
as there is now
and
the speaker
formed a fourth division
which represented army and i were put on
to solve
the education funding thing
and we worked
every day
sundays etc for a long time and we came
up with this
six six weeks six and a half days a week
yep he gave a sunday morning off
yes
i got a bad back
well we got it done
and it still works today
uh any other comments
representative spellsbury thank you mr
chairman
um
yes i also support having legislation on
this tangled subject before the
committee during the coming term
one thing that i wonder though
in the complaint
on page nine that second page
paragraph
29 says
it says
of the action that this legislature took
last year
to reduce the swept collections by 100
million
it says this temporarily eliminated the
surplus swept revenues that property
wealthy towns have previously failed to
send to the state
and instead of kept for themselves so i
think it's an interesting thing to note
while that doesn't address all that this
bill is concerned with
an incidental effect you could say
benefit
of the 100 million dollar reduction
was that it effectively
suspended
i may just
represent
ames just to note that
that change was accompanied with a grant
to the property wealthy
communities
that
was fashioned as a hold harmless that
essentially made up
for what they could no longer retain
so
further questions or comments on house
send none
representative
so
i guess we're all we're the senses that
we're we're probably going to move
forward with
something
so what's the plan i mean this is a big
topic
i mean is it going to be a handful of
people getting in a room coming up with
a bill
or
i guess you could file a bill
i mean i
you know i'm big on commissions and we
probably had a million commissions on
this
if i don't know how many commissions
we've had on this topic
over the years
i don't know either the most uh recent
i'll start over i i don't know uh how
many there have been
in my time
most recently and i sat on this one was
uh the commission on
school funding
that ended its work in late 2020
before that there was one that
representative umberger chaired
there was a committee not a commission
and uh that uh did its work uh one or
two years before the maybe one or one
year before the startup of the
commission that i just spoke of
and uh back in uh 2009
or s or eight probably eight um
there was a uh
a committee that did uh groundbreaking
work on this uh this effort um and uh
that was a
uh that was a legislative committee as
well a joint committee um
and uh it's the product of their work
that carried forward through the years
in the form of a state stabilization
grant after much of the language of the
of uh of their changes had been cleaned
out um
there was this consensus that uh
that the funding
needed to be carried forward and so a
stabilization grant was devised that
essentially did that
with a
shrinking aspect to it four percent per
year but then that
in recent years was taken away so it's
it's uh it's a mishmash of uh things
that we've got here that are the product
of
of uh
of joint work you write about that and
uh people getting together and trying to
figure out what to do in a
on a matter that seems to defy solution
how we how we proceed with this and i
think the traditional way is that
legislators go back
at this stage in the you know in the
year go back and
someone comes forward with a bill that
may be the product of behind the scenes
work with others or may not be
i don't i don't know what to suggest
here i i will go back i
glad to confer with whoever wants to
confer with me
um in an informal process
representative romney yeah i i
this this would be a major bill
it'd be great if it could be a
bipartisan bill
um
that i worked on just says
these two did in
2000 and what was that 1998 all right
so
uh but i know i understand i mean we
don't really have time to do that
um
i i don't know i just it just seems like
we're gonna do a bill
the bill may be it's up to the committee
you know how we're all in a rush
uh you know with our bills three months
we have to work on a bill
uh
and that
you know but if it's the first term
build and then there's
the bill can be retained and continue to
be worked on uh i would imagine that way
um
assuming that that we can't get
agreement and uh you know
but all right now that's my thoughts
that's all if i may just add one thing
to uh there is uh actually is today at
10 30 uh the education committee is
coming
into a meeting to
to
do its work on an interim study of house
bill 1680
which is a comprehension effort to make
a comprehensive reform of the school
funding
system included in that bill actually as
the
other provisions of house bill 504 as a
subset of the larger bill
and that's going to be discussed in
detail at uh at this education committee
meeting
uh
so there's this other aspect of it it's
a part of a much bigger picture and
packages absolutely thank you
representative aaron
thank you mr chair
so my predecessor for sullivan county
district 7 representative
jim grenier was on that education
committee that
examined school funding back in 19
and
i wonder so what happened with the
results from that and the
recommendations from that committee did
anybody do anything with it do you know
anybody
you know i i i don't remember
specifically i think the worst uh
for one thing representative umberger
didn't return um in in the next
legislature
so she wasn't here to you know shepherd
the results of the commission there were
parts of it i think that made their way
into uh legislation you could ask the
education committee representatives who
are here if you
want a better answer than i can provide
on that
but maybe that's a detour that the chair
okay any further questions or comments
thank you on
this
what is what gets done is going to
on scitec shaped
the original agreement
on
if
and we don't we won't know
on
what has to be done if they decide
not until the supreme court
uh
makes a decision
for us
and in the meantime we could be doing
one thing and the supreme court would
decide it was still
improper and that would take a number of
years more to figure out um
we had it was not easy the first time we
on while we were meeting they
put out the sales tax and the income tax
bills that were
on
the income tax bill in particular would
have
solved this but the governor as well as
a lot of people in the state did not
want it
uh and that one
eventually uh failed because of that
on and meanwhile we were still working
as i remember
and we came up with something that got
called the poo poo plan
a bit of all sorts of things it took uh
eight hours of debate i think it was
after midnight when we finished
finally
things got taken out they got put back
again
on
and we finally passed that and then over
succeeding years there were was more
work done on it
so um
we have to be
prepared if the court actually produces
a decision which doesn't say
what you're doing is fine
then
on
on that it's not going to be
one bill and quick
what i've heard here this morning
is that
a bill is really needed
work really needs to be done
we want that we
put forth
let me so i
made it right
we have only two things we can do
either
not recommend for future legislation or
recommend for future legislation
and i think
is that an order
oh we're not in the executive session
what's that i was i was asking if i
could make a motion but we're not in the
executive session so
we could move to government names
for a motion
uh to go into executive session to
consider second session or you maybe you
have to do that
you have to listen to executive session
oh
absolutely right
i'm getting old at this time
thanks representative ames and we will
now go into executive session
and
i recommend that this committee uh
um
[Music]
recommend
this bill for future legislation is that
the right way to put it
i second that motion
yes i second that
okay the motion has been made and
seconded
that that this committee recommends
uh the future
if not
then we're going to call the vote
thank you mr chair
uh roll call no call we'll begin the
voting on h.p 504 the motion is to
recommend for future legislation begin
the voting with representative abrami
yes
representative
the clerk votes yes
representative aaron
yes
representative spillsbury
representative tudor
yes representative almi
representative ames yes representative
southworth yes representative malloy yes
the honorable representative thomas c
schomburg
thank you mr clerk yes
thank you sir representative tucker yes
one two three four five
oh and the chair
six eight ten twelve fourteen fifteen
sixteen enough
vote being sixteen to zero
any objections to put it on the consent
calendar
no
fine
what we do here is that
we think this needs to be a meeting
again
that's a session
right
i think there has to be a little blurb
and we need to get that report out by
the 28th of october
so so do we leave it that i i will uh
draft a report and send it to you yes
yes okay
thank you
that's
actually reducing the rate of the meals
and rooms tax and increasing the revenue
sharing of meals and rooms tax revenue
do we have any questions or comments
from
anybody
representative
i said i guess i'll start here
um
you know we we've reduced a lot of taxes
over the last couple years and we're in
the middle of reducing the
interest and dividends tax
a percent every year going forward
um
i don't think reducing the
moving meals tax
as prescribed here
is a good idea and then i know they want
to redirect
more of the money to the
which
it would be
you know a pretty sizable hit in our on
our revenues
um
and i think when it comes to
you know next year
we have to take a look at the big
picture in terms of all our revenues
um and i don't think we want to start by
us suggesting that we want to reduce
the meals and rooms tax
just my general comment so i would be a
further questions or comments
rubs and elneny
thank you on i
completely agree
i think that next year is a year for
taking stock of what is going on and
trying to figure out where we're going
to start to be
even by the end of of
this fiscal year we're in never mind the
next fiscal year what it's going to look
like
before we make any more
changes that cost us revenue
right and i i agree with you represent
elmi the
changes that we've already passed some
of them haven't been fully implemented
and they are in the process of being
implemented
this year next year and the following
year and the following year after that
one of the big things i worry about is
that
we in every other state is doing great
right now with revenues
the primary reason for that
is all the stimulus checks that went to
all the individuals
the
opera money that went out the ppp money
and
brought in revenue that we hadn't
anticipated
and that's going to
the result of that's going to be going
away and we need to wait and see what
that settles down to
because that's going to be settling down
the same time as we're continuing to ink
to reduce
our tax revenues
any further questions or comments
i want to follow up with the
representative so yeah i mean the opera
money's still being spent i mean it's
some of our i know some of our state
opera money hasn't even been obligated
yet
it may never be i guess
but it's
there's money that's still going out the
door i know the county in
rockingham
we got six we got 60 million
and uh a lot of that's going to go to a
new
building for
some outpatient services and things like
that and housing some of our agencies
but
um
but all that money hasn't been spent
either so
um
i mean that just
yeah and and
uh major is correct uh you know we we
don't stand alone when i talk to people
legislated from other states they're all
saying that they're washing money too
so there's something's up here
that something is gonna eventually we
would i know for the last two years
we've all been waiting for the shoot to
shoot a drop the other shooter dropped
and we haven't gotten there yet but i
think we just have to be cautious it's
it's coming yeah
thank you
reps indonesian
thank you mr chairman
i just wanted to also say that i i agree
that we should not move this forward um
it's
each each tax and some of the taxes that
we've produced
um
definitely
we've seen you know for example the
business profits tax we've seen over
time even prior to
is that better yes okay
i was just saying so we have seen that
some of the other taxes we reduced like
the business profits tax and i'm talking
even before covid
did have an increase in business
activity
um
this this
i'm not sure how given the i agree with
the concerns that we don't know how much
things are going to be affected
i don't see this reducing this tax as
being
a major driver
of new business right now so i think
it's probably better
given the given the amounts here to
leave this as it is
any further questions or comments
represents spillsbury thank you mr
chairman i thought when we reviewed this
uh bill that it sort of represented an
internal conflict or at least a choice
on the one hand it proposes to reduce
the rate and on the other hand it
proposes to share more of what's
collected
and
the idea
of
increasing the share to the
municipalities
is very attractive to me
if we found ourselves in a future
legislature where the circumstances and
the revenue supported that
decision i think i would be in favor of
it
but i probably wouldn't be reducing the
followed by representative brandon
thank you on
we have to be very careful when we're
looking at what our
tax reduction
on
on policy was that we look also at the
economic activity that was producing the
surge in revenues they don't match up
um
if you
we have that from the dra
now that they've got excellent analysts
and they've got very good
data collection for which we didn't have
the
we don't have any idea yet what the
change to single sales factor is going
to do to our business tax
it could be
nothing it could be drastic
and we won't know
until
anything
about that i think
there will be some small indication
maybe from
analyzing what market-based sourcing did
next year
but
um
that
gives me the willies
the credit carry forward gives our chair
the willies
which is
huge and
can be asked for back
and we also we've been assuming that
there would be more refunds
this year than there have been
uh from the ppp
and um
i think the refunds are up a little
but not much
um so far
on it's i described the credit carry
forward situation to
a
very good accountant and she kind of
went white
but
so we really
and we have the
on almost certainly triggering off that
recession that hadn't come yet
on
by continuing to raise rates to make
sure that we don't get into the kind of
runaway inflation that i have
experienced twice in
in my life as
uh once in brazil and once here when i
was a young professional
and
on
so
they need fed needs to do what it needs
to do but it's on we're not we don't
have any good choices
on that
so
and we don't know i think one of the
things this committee can do next year
is to try to get
information from lbao on
on the finance side of these things what
on
what
sectors of industry in this state have
been
most affected
by the stimulus that's gone out
and
what's happening to them to the extent
that we can
and that may help with what
representative abrami has been
about there's still arpa money going out
and some other and there's still the
uh ira going out and there's still uh
the transportation money going out
on it's in specific defined sectors and
we don't even know what most of the
sectors are at this point because it's
all being the arpa money's all coming
through the governor
representative romney
hb2 correct
and it was it was sitting around 21 22
percent before that's correct
so
it was a 22 before so
this budget year based this this budget
cycle they did a little part retain
stayed it was an increase to 30 percent
and then moving to 40 i know that was
the original target right going way back
but we never got there because every
every budget finance committee
they always
chop it down when we're looking for
revenues
so
you know i don't know if we have to get
to the 40
you know what i mean because it's one of
those things in that
we can say anything we want in a bill
but when hb2 comes along that can change
uh when they're looking for money
so
um but at the very least for this budget
for this budget that we're in
we know that it's gone up or maybe eight
percent to 30 percent for the towns
thank you
and that hasn't settled in yet so that
that will be happening
um
corruption aaron
thank you mr chairman
so
i heard some ideas floated around uh
first first of all question about
uh funds that are collected from this
how much of it goes to our travel and
tourism
agency or department in the state is
there a portion of this
that is allocated or is that just done
through the budget the state budget
process
do you have anything to add to that
that's right okay
something on there is money allocated
each year
for the advertising budget it used to be
very small
we
increased it uh
in
on
and ever since then until we hit this
very sharp recession with covet
on
rooms and meals it's been going up about
five percent a year
which i thought and we all thought and
finance thought was a very good return
on investment
and it was reduced a lot in 11
12 but i think just for one year
and then they
put it back up again
follow-up question
the reason i'm asking is because there
was someone who suggested to me
that they wanted to take
some portion of what we collect in rooms
and meals tax
and
i know that the
travel and tourism department does
mostly marketing stuff
but there's no real
development
happening
for tourism in any of our counties and
except i know in sullivan county we have
a sugar river development council
that is uh working on
developing
tourism in in our in our in our county
and so they're looking for ways in which
to fund that effort
and and so i i don't know if you've
heard of any kind of other
uh initiatives that are trying to tap
into rooms and meals tax
i i'm not sure but that would be a
question for the appropriators and the
finance committee can make the decision
oh
okay there there is actually a
fairly large initiative being put on by
taylor caswell's
development
um
agency whose new name i never can
remember the former dread right now
now two agencies and there is actually a
statewide initiative
the
executive council has approved a
contract
with an agency that's outside group
that's been employed to
see what we can do to
broaden and strengthen
our outdoor recreation in the state of
new hampshire and it's
just getting off the ground
uh
and it's going to be much more
regularized standardized and expanded
so i think we all need to keep an eye on
that some people want to keep things
quite local others are keen to
make it more statewide i think that's
being decided in the next year or two
taylor caswell's taking an initiative in
this area it's backed by the governor
and many
uh groups like appalachian mountain club
trails groups very enthusiastic about
broadening bicycling kayaking all kinds
of things
so what you're saying is the executive
is doing their job
i i think they really are getting uh yes
and uh
i think
to tie it to
rooms and meals may not be
in the best interest of
sort of a slope of activity going upward
right
because it would be affected by sort of
this
fits and starts of
of a particular year of
tourism and i think they're trying to
get away from that that's my
understanding i haven't had a briefing
on the topic it's only from what i've
read
i agree with you
and
[Music]
we don't giving up the pie we just
then do i hear a motion
session
yes we need to go under executive
i guess we're still in it but that's all
right
no we never went out
all right why don't we just
i'll make the motion
representative ron
i'll make the motion uh
that uh well let me use the right words
here
that we don't recommend this for future
legislation
second
okay the motion made by representative
romney not to
recommend
the future legislation
seconded by representative
elmig
any
okay we've had enough discussion so i'll
ask the clerk to call the roll
thank you mr chair
house bill 1204 the motion is to not
recommend for future legislation
we'll begin the voting with
representative obrami yes
representative hollery yes the clerk
votes yes representative aaron
yes
representative genigen yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes representative
almi
yes representative ames
yes representative southworth yes
representative malloy yes the honorable
thomas c schomburg
yes
representative tucker yes representative
gomarlo
representative hacken phillips yes
16 to nothing
i'm sorry
chairman major
the bug being 16 to nothing the motion
and can i put down representative abrami
i i went into karen and asked and they
to quote a former president wear a
okay our next bill is house bill
1500-fn-a
an act reducing the rate of the
communication service tax and repealing
the tax
in 2025.
and this repeals the tax
wraps and yearly
representative
um
major mr chair thank you very much
uh the
question that should always be on this
particular tax this is more of a
user fee than a tax and it's not really
a it's called a communications tax but
if i'm not mistaken the monies go almost
exclusively to operating the e 911
system
so
if future legislation is goes forward
the
amount of this
fee should likely be tied to the cost to
operate
am i saying that
correctly
there was
i believe
that the 911 was an additional
p
put on top of the regular fee
so
that the bulk of it
does not go to 911 but 911 is serviced
by it
well if this is just
a tax tax to raise
money
then
who cares but if the money is tied
directly to
a usage or a service provided by the
state that's entirely different and
whichever way the vote comes out of
committee today
that distinction
should be made
so if uh
regardless of how we're going to do it
that that should be done
right
thank you mr chairman um
yeah looking back at my notes i saw that
one of the reasons we had put this off
was because we could not figure out the
impact
of this tax given that uh landline
still not close enough given that
landline uh communication
uh was decreasing and we brought up the
question about uh products such as zoom
that use um and and the like that use
communication services
but one of the major reasons we didn't
move forward was because we we didn't
couldn't really identify
the size of this
decrease
so i mean i think
to move ahead with something where we
can't really identify this needs
this needs more study um i probably
would
recommend that we not
move forward with this at this point and
if uh you know
more research is done and we get more
information on it this could be brought
uh back again
thank you uh representative
and
and followed by representative hacken
phillips
thank you on
i
this
is not this does not go to the e911
system except that it goes to the
general fund and maybe the general fund
helps
uh with this one
on
this but this is it used to be a major
tax when all we had was landlines
on and when on the communications
companies couldn't play games with how
much was being taxed
on
we on got on grand we got on
grandfathered
two years before the feds on
grandfathered everybody on this and we
can't use it for
internet stuff
if you spend a lot of time going down
through your phone bill
you may
discover that
on you are paying maybe a dollar
a month
in this tax at the most
on
they they really
uh have
said it so that
if when you are making a phone call
phone calls the same number of phone
calls i used to make on my landline i'm
making them on my cell phone and my
landline and the bills
are
paying doing that i think it's seven
percent on
a
very
much smaller
uh number uh amount
of
my activity that is what
that is
on not internet
uh
except that it's going over the internet
now everything is going over the
internet
so um
it's
shrunk to
around 32 at this point million 39.6
39.6 that was the
revenue for 21. we were still getting
39.6 out of it but it's going down every
year
but
39.6 million
pays for
39.6 million worth of
programs that the state does
for
the
businesses the
communities and the households
and
every time we cut revenues
those programs
get cut too the money has to come from
somewhere and they end up in the hands
of the municipalities
and the municipalities cannot do those
particular programs as efficiently
as
as the state can
so we are increasing the tax burden on
the citizens and saying that we
decreased it this is true across our tax
system at this point the property taxes
keep going up
and the
state taxes
either stay the same
or
or they go up in
in our case in spurts
a year or two after
after the
the tax was changed
and
uh
we really
until we
totally reform the tax system which i
think won't happen in my lifetime
we've got we've got to recognize this
we've got to deal with this
when we are cutting further into our
revenues
um in a good time when we get to the bad
time
things fall apart on
i've got social service agencies that
didn't get paid for six months
all of a sudden
and had to depend on local donations to
try to stay open for senior citizens and
open
and
and the county taxes had to go up to pay
for more in the nursing homes
on
that's been going on since 20
the whole time i've been there
this is associated with the
communication yes it is um
i
i think that any
recommending any uh
tax reduction to go forward in the next
term when we haven't figured out what's
going on is
on
is not in the interests of of the state
representative phillips
thank you mr chair um
just to follow off those last sets of
comments um is it's my sense that the
reasoning that we were not suggesting
legislation moved forward on hb
1204 also applies to hb 1500 and that
you know
i would urge caution for us to be able
to assess recent reductions in tax
revenues
um in the coming months so that we can
get a better grasp of what's going on
before we make another you know
potential reduction of 39 million plus
million dollars so
um
you know it's my it's my thought that
you know if we're going to be
intellectually honest that we should
continue to
um remember the comments we made just a
few moments ago
and to um to apply that to hb 500 1500
as well thank you mr chair
thank you
thank you mr chair i so my my thought is
similar i'd i'd like to just know before
we start cutting any kind of
revenue like this that we have a good
understanding of
what this funds
and how that would affect them
should we cut this so
i think
i don't know that we as a committee have
a full understanding of uh what what the
39.6 million dollars is going towards
and
if if it has
value
or they're good programs i don't know
representative brownie
well to answer that question i i don't
think the these funds are really
earmarked
for a specific thing i think they want
to
in the general fund
and
and you know it's up to finance how they
they spend that money but we could find
out how many how many
if there's anything related to telecom
that's
that general fund money is being used
for
so
uh same same arguments as before
as the last bill
we don't know and and note in the in the
bill
sorry
would represent hawker and phillips want
to make the motion
i wanted to make a comment
okay representative talker first uh
one of the things that i think is um
oh no
one of the things that i think is true
about new hampshire is that we have a
large number
of revenue sources
unlike most states which are quite
dependent on a very few revenue sources
and over time
this has allowed for stability
for new hampshire that has not been true
of some other states so before we cut
out all these little
uh
sources of revenue i think we need to
have a better appreciation
of how
new hampshire has managed to live
without sales and income tax and it has
to do with a broad
number
and we've added to it with
charitable gaming sports betting you
know we've done uh some things that have
brought in revenues
uh as other things have fallen but we
have kept a large number of revenue
sources and i think that
probably that's where the committee
should start next
uh year in the orientation is getting a
better more formal grasp
of what of that truth that more revenue
sources it isn't
added revenues it's the number of
sources is a real plus for this state
okay before i go to park uh
hacking phillips i apologize for cutting
representative brown in the office
around me yeah the chair thought i was
making a motion i don't know i was i
didn't know no no no no he thought i was
making a motion i no i was i was just
commenting you know
representative uh tucker yeah absolutely
right
that we've had these these all these
different taxes
little ones
that have really helped us in
downturns
maybe that biz maybe business taxes
declined but other ones have stayed
stayed fine
and that that's helped us out of
recessions over the time because our
recession seemed to be
less we have a smaller trough
right right right we kind of smooth it
with all these smaller taxes so
and i again for the reasons i stated in
the prior bill i i i don't think uh we
need to to get rid of this tax it's
already kind of baked into everybody's
phone bills knowing that most people
didn't realize it's there
and uh
and
and i understand that the the analysis
the dra was a static analysis
for just the reasons we talked about
because they didn't know they don't know
because this this this is a tax that's
in transition
and as we in terms of of the different
products that are being taxed and not
taxed
so i get i think even the dra is trying
to get a handle on that as to
whether the
what we're going to tax is going up or
what we're going to tax is going down so
anyway i i would i would i don't want to
make the motion but i'll i'll support a
no motion if someone makes that
before we go to the motion
representative phillips representative
bernstein
yeah i just i think it's important to
um at least cite the other side of the
argument the the sponsor of the bill
um
said that this would save new hampshire
families about three to five dollars a
month he also pointed out that this is
as regressive of a tax as you can get it
it's not dependent on your income it's
dependent on your cell phone bill which
is pretty much a necessity now so it's
extremely regressive
and then look we all understand that the
revenue from this tax continues to go
down as landlines are used less and less
there's a cost to collecting the tax
and as the revenue drops we're just not
getting as good of a bang for our buck
as we were in previous years
so
if if you are going to cut taxes this
would be a good one one final point
where meals and rooms tax
business profits tax
sometimes benefits non-residents of new
hampshire a reduction of this tax or an
elimination of this tax would be to the
sole benefit of new hampshire residents
and taxpayers
and i think um i mean i'm hearing a lot
of the arguments from the other side i
just think it's important to highlight
the other position
representative
thank you i just want to clear something
up for representative aaron the finance
committee
just as as we don't appropriate money
the finance committee
doesn't designate
money for specific places unless they
create a dedicated fund
if they create a dedicated fund it is no
longer in the regular budget
so
on
that
39.7 million
went to
into a general
pool
and cannot be determined as to what it's
paying for
but
we can look at the general pool and say
that it is getting bigger or it is
getting smaller and when it is getting
smaller
then on
it's frequently the departments that
have to decide what they're cutting out
of their budgets
and what they're delaying paying for
and sometimes never paying for
when we run into a recessionary period
and because it's past the budget time
when we realize that there aren't enough
revenues
and so
the department commit the commissioners
who are
appointed for
four to six
four to five years each
are the ones who make that decision
and they may or may not be influenced by
the governor if it's a good governor the
representative hack on phillips
thank you mr chair are we in executive
session now yes okay great um i'd like
to make a motion that this committee
not recommend hp 1500 for future
legislation
welcome
representative hacken phillips made the
motion not to recommend we have a second
any further
questions or comments
saying none i'll ask the quote to follow
thank you mr chair the bill is house
bill 1500 the motion is to not recommend
this bill for future legislation we'll
begin the voting with representative
obrami yes
representative hollery no
the clerk votes no
representative genigean yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes
representative almi
representative ames
yes representative southworth yes
representative malloy yes
the honorable representative thomas c
schomburg
your voice is so calming
yes representative tucker yes
representative hacken phillips yes
the motion
representative hacken phillips can i
note you as the author of the report
establishing a county nursing home
questions or comments uh
rebs and aaron
well since this was my bill i'd like to
speak to it
thank you mr chair
so
originally i i was seeking to have a
state fund established
a capital reserve fund to help our
counties
deal with some of the escalating costs
of renovating or rebuilding
their county nursing home facilities as
a result of federal guidelines that have
affected the cost
of building these uh or doing
renovations
i know that um now
the
federal guidelines institute the fgi
which dictates
how much space you need per resident
and other space requirements within a
facility
are they are
going to private rooms only for our for
our nursing home facilities
as opposed to you know allowing
semi-private rooms or uh three people to
a room
so that that
is a huge cost for our counties when
they're doing these renovations and and
rebuilds
so um
i think it might be a good idea to to
keep an eye on um what's happening with
some of the costs for our counties with
regard to the renovating their
facilities
i know for the time being
a um
a fund has been set up that has been
funded with arpa money through the
gopher
agency
and
right now counties can apply for some
arpa extra arpa and
funding for them to do that for example
sullivan county
is uh requesting some funds from this
fund that was established and the fund
but this is a short-term kind of
solution because it's with arpa funds
and it is um not
going to be there forever
so
it it might be worth looking at um
establishing some sort of
county
capital reserve fund at the state level
at some point
because as our counties continue to want
to renovate
and update their facilities they are
going to need some help to do it it's
just becoming
way too cost prohibitive
to rely on just their
taxpayers for their counties and that's
additional questions or comments
represent southward
thank you
i don't have really an issue with going
forward as she said and studying this
because i do think in some areas that
may reach actually a crisis level you
know as we go on so we might as well
any further questions or comments
am i am i hearing that
representative
so
would the recommendation be
to consider continue
to come up with a bill to continue to
study this issue versus this bill
is what i'm trying to understand
if we would say yes to this would it be
more to study
the approach
because again it comes back to the same
old problem you know there are 10
counties
who gets the money
many many counties have already paid for
new or renovated nursing homes already
uh all politics is local
um
so
i wouldn't mind if if you said yeah i
would make you know in the blurb it said
that that if you made the motion yes
if you said that to continue to study
would be one thing but
i don't know if i'd you know be back in
the same place
next year if it was the same bill
i think that's my opinion
the motion that we can have is one of
two
to recommend for future legislative
legislation or not recommended
and it doesn't say what's in it
reptilie
thank you and
i agree in many ways with representative
abrami
um
we added a new wing and rehabilitated
everything else about 15 years ago i
think we finished
uh
and we cut the budget too low and then
had to add more money later on to pay
for it
because
we'd been
taken the fed's had had
behind us
but
and i think one thing we have to do as a
state is to go after that
board
along with all the other states and get
them to understand that it's going to be
really difficult to afford
uh the baby boomers going through the
nursing homes if we're doing it in
single room
occupancy
but
for this one i think that if we
we
the one thing we could do is not
recommended and in the blurbs say but a
let me remind you this
whatever we do here either recommend or
not recommend
so
mr chair mr chair over here
rubs and rams
yeah
i you know i actually i'm okay
if it says recommend for future
legislation or recommend against
um i i'm perfectly happy to be for
future legislation with a blurb that
makes it clear that what we're
we're for is
a is a study of
da da
and that's good enough for me and it uh
it
essentially says
there's a problem here that needs to be
addressed but we don't know exactly what
it is and
it's essentially sending the message
that what we have in front of us isn't
quite right
so that sort of addresses the no side of
this discussion but it uh
it
says we got to deal with this and that's
represent aaron
you've heard the discussion
that uh before we go back to you reps
and
um thank you mr chair
one thing that hasn't been uh remarked
on
is that unlike the municipalities
counties have their own existence
separate from the state they they exist
separate from the state that matter of
fact
many people would say they pre-exist the
state
therefore each county can do
what it wants under our constitution
towns and cities can't
the county can each of the other
counties has taken their own
actions regarding a wide variety of
cases from stopping to maintaining uh
county roads
to
establishing a nursing home to
maintaining or not maintaining
uh at least in two situations uh
county jails
it's up to the county which has its own
existence to deal with that separate
from the state now whether the state
should get involved in the counties thus
decreasing the authority of the counties
i know there was some legislation in the
past to re
remove the counties which would have
required a constitutional amendment but
um that
do we the the question is do we want the
counties to be counties
or do we want this to be
one big state
1.7 million people
it takes three hours to get from one
side of the town to the other of course
los angeles has got more and it takes
robson and aaron
yes and one thing thank you for that
and one thing i do want to add is that
our counties are not statutorily
obligated to have nursing home
facilities
so i mean there's that
but
the
fact of the matter is the counties are
still charged by the state
money
for to take care of their citizens
and
money is going back from the counties to
the state to do that
um
so
we do have a a uh
a um
you know a situation where
we are
we are beholden to the state for for
funds you know that we have to give the
state funds
um but by the same token in providing
these medical services for our
low-income
seniors and and people who need them
it's becoming that much more
expensive for our counties to do this
based on outside so you know outside
things that we have no control over
and that's a problem and i think that's
something that at least we have to keep
an eye on and and possibly study and
take a seat take a look and see
uh
how that's affecting everything
so if you
make a motion
but for the right recommendation and in
the blurred uh
talk about study
any further questions or comments
uh represented
i mean
we
so i'd make a motion to
to uh study that to um
i'd recommend this for future study
for future legislation future
legislation to study the issue
explaining
i'll second that mr chairman and
then saying none
mr clark could call the roll
thank you mr chair it's house bill 1525
the motion is to recommend for future
legislation we'll begin the voting with
representative abrami yes
representative orry yes
the clerk votes yes representative aaron
yes representative genigean yes
representative spillsberry yes
representative tudor yes representative
almi yes representative ames yes
representative southworth yes
representative malloy
yes
the honorable representative thomas c
schomburg since this is your last roll
call mr clerk i'd like to there's one
more i'll save my uh
representative tucker yes representative
gomarlo
representative hacken phillips yes
chairman major
yes
did i get everyone
16 to nothing
okay
i missed it
since the vote being 16 to nothing the
motion of recommended for future
legislation passes
uh house bill 1565-fn
relative to the opioid abatement trust
fund
robinson southwood
uh thank you mr chairman
so this is one that i followed closely
in my career i was very aware of the
crisis and
you know the broad effects
um
i was uh
interested in reading the rules
um but i found they didn't have some of
the details that i would like there
basically will be competitive grant
programs for the funds
at the county and municipal level
one of my issues with grants that are
competitive is some counties are much
better at writing grants and dotting
eyes and crossing t's and the same with
municipalities so i'm just hoping the
people overseeing the grants recognize
that with the opioid crisis there are
areas of the state with greater need
than others
and those may not be the same match as
the people who are the best at writing
grants and so i do really think uh there
has to be this overview
i also think they should make some of it
uh as easy as they can for example most
communities need help affording the cost
of narcan
so i'd like to see some type of rule
where you know it's relatively easy to
document your usage of narcan and get
reimbursed and so on um again so it's
very even in in terms of the
disbursement
um
to me this program is i mean the problem
is gigantic and i still think sometimes
people don't quite grab onto it um
in our county uh we have a diversion
program and we have individuals uh you
know that are working uh
can't even decide what word you'd use
but you know they are addicts and they
are working very hard
but when we have what sometimes our
graduation ceremonies they have a lawyer
family members a social worker
one or two doctors a court system person
there there are seven to ten people
for each case
uh and then they may relapse so i think
and i also didn't mention that probably
someone from their business
uh their boss or someone who is
supporting them from their business so
it really uh it's very large
and i don't you know what i'm hearing so
far i'm not sure we even yet know the
best way really to address it we have
different programs that work but i'm not
at all sure
we have the big picture
of how to address it
so again i you know i think it will
really depend on helping people writing
the right grants having overviews
all those kinds of things i just see it
as quite complicated
and i don't see based on this bill
that we can really make a change right
now
because the funds are just beginning to
come in they're just beginning to
disperse them so it seems to me um
really we aren't even there yet as far
as deciding we need to change something
about the approach
uh and the only other thing i'd add is
um you know for people who haven't had
the experience
if you do know someone who's been
through this
and uh you know has used fentanyl when
they're taking care of the young
children and died there with them um you
know this is what's happening all around
the state still
oh thank you
so my recommendation is that we not move
forward
represents billsbury
thank you mr chairman
i concur
it just seems to me that the specific
ways and means context
of allocating funds has become moot the
program's sailing ahead
and i'm sure oversight and review from
the appropriate committee will be in
order for the next legislature but i
don't see the role of this committee in
representative aaron
thank you mr chair so just a reminder of
the the
intent of this bill
to begin with
was to
alter
the allocation formula
so that
counties were not being
um
[Music]
given a a
a penalty
based on population
and
because their programs are different
than the programs that municipalities
might have established
and so
if you had say sullivan county
getting penalized for
uh claremont
the population of claremont being taken
out of their amount a pot of money
that it wasn't this this bill sought to
fix that
some people saw that as double counting
i don't see it as double counting
but in any case i mean the the
allocation formula that we currently
have was something that was put together
by a
a judge from another
state
and there have been states who have
already altered their allocation
formulas
away from what that judge had decided
i guess there's some wisdom in in
looking to see uh
where everything shakes out when funds
start flowing and money gets allocated
out
but by the same token i think that
there's going to be this mentality
afterwards that's going to say
oh well
we can't change it now because we've
already started allocating money
and and i think that's unfortunate
because we will lose
the opportunity to kind of fine-tune it
and get it right in terms of how we
allocate the funds coming in from these
opioid settlements
so that's all i have to say about this
bill i
again
would like to see some more
for us to to to see some reports and see
how money is being allocated especially
with the grants that are
being set up
um and i'd like to see how effective
these out the current allocation is as
opposed to what we could have
in the future so i'd like to keep an eye
on it and maybe study it in the future
representable
okay so
so
the way it's set up now is that 23
original political subdivisions that had
filed lawsuits
and i would assume sullivan calling it
was one of those divisions yes correct
all the counties i think were uh
and i know we spent a lot of time on
this bill and we heard from the a.g
let's get his name now patheti
from the ag's office who
uh basically put the
i guess the words around
uh are
our procedure if you will
that we're using and and in the fund
there is another
committee or i don't know what you want
to call it a a trust fund committee
that's making these decisions about
these grant requests come in and then we
have to approve them
so that's all in place
uh
and i know we just had another
settlement right j j
was it j j
yeah
47 minutes right so
so i don't even know what yeah i agree
with you one one thing representative is
that yes
we we need to keep an eye on this to see
i think the question is you're bringing
up his fairness will will the
will the grants be allocated in a fair
way and will
the counties be
be treated you know not
i know right now the allocation of the
15 goes based on pop population correct
so
in your small county so i understand
your your concern
and your problem may be bigger than
just
you know
probably be disportioned to your
population i guess what you
so
you know but at this point i think it's
a matter of of us as a committee
keeping an eye on this and i i wouldn't
necessarily recommend future recommend
legislation
but maybe some kind of an oversight as
to
maybe periodically calling in
the
uh the folks overseeing this fund to see
if
you know i'm not going to say i'm not
going to i'm not saying that they're not
going to be fair
but it'd be interesting to see how the
money is being allocated uh
to the various communities so i'm all
set thank you and i saw i'll be
supporting a no motion
representative
thank you on
i think i agree with uh representative
spillsbury
that
this is something that the health and
human services committee
should be evaluating
uh as we go forward we've been kind of
had had a difficulty with this partly
because um the
the committee that was formed to
to deal with this which is
led by
senator rosenwald
on
does come more from that side of things
and is
has has named
the aag buffetti as uh
as their sole spokesperson
on this which
um
i tried to get
senator rosenwald to come and talk to us
too about what they were planning on
doing because a number of the questions
especially about
help for the communities that don't know
how to write grants very well on
was
on
and the narcan program were
on mentioned as things they were trying
to get through in the rule that they
couldn't do until the rules had gotten
through jail car
i think the roles got through jail car
recently
very recently
but we don't know what the results of
that
will be but on what senator rosenwald
said was
was we don't know what we're doing until
the rules have allowed us to meet and
make those votes
which i don't know if that's happened
yet
but
um
i do think that
that unless that
those initiatives uh
don't work out
that uh in practice i think that the
the health and human services committee
is the one that can evaluate that better
than
than we can
and actually that this bill
is more about
well it was about a dedicated fund and
that's how it landed here i think
but it was
was was about essentially about where
you appropriate the money
and that's
a finance question
and then health and human services
question because that's the department
that does it
uh i'm i'm for a no vote at this point
but
if things don't work out then
you got a better sense of this bill when
you look at the mythology that's printed
and
you read that and
may it would put me on the no
path anything else
and just briefly mr chair
it just occurred to me that
the
paperwork that uh was handed out at the
beginning by representative ames in 504
particularly the
equitable and proportional case came out
if that case is decided saying that the
distribution has to be equitable and
proportional the ramifications of that
would
then be that regardless of what formula
was done for any distribution
of funds received from any source would
therefore have to be equitable and
proportional
so that
what was being attempted by this bill
couldn't happen
because it wouldn't be equitable and
proportional it would be
beneficial to one
county over another
because of population and their size
so there's a lot of
factors that go into this beyond
what was attempted but i think i've
raised other questions that
representative almighty wants to comment
on
perhaps an omni
well
one of the lawyers might be better at
this but
on
the reason that
the courts
opine on the education side is that they
created on from the language in the
constitution which is pretty clear
they established that uh we owe
everybody an adequate education
and i don't think we've owed decided we
owe everybody
adequate health access
yet
well hopefully not ever but
uh i'd not
be in favor of that one but i think
that's yours
no problem thank you mr chair
i don't want to write a second blur but
i move that no
further legislation needed on this bill
not recommended for further legislation
thank you
second
okay representative romney moved
secondly by representing alani
foreign thank you mr chair house bill
1565 the motion is to not recommend this
for future legislation we'll begin the
representative olivery yes the clerk
votes yes
representative aaron
yes
representative genegan yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes representative
almi
yes representative ames yes
representative southworth yes
yes
and it saddens me to say these words for
the final time but the honorable
representative thomas c schomburg uh mr
clerk before i cast my vote i'd like to
thank you for your two years of
respecting and the way you addressed all
the representatives with their title and
the chair
some committees don't do that so i
appreciate even though you add the word
honorable to our mind everyone here is
very honorable so
my vote is would you vote representative
romney
thank you representative
representative tucker yes
representative go marlow
yes
16 love
the vote being 16 to zero the motion
passes
um
that finishes
our work on bills
i have a note here
anybody that's not returning
if they would clean out their draws
and i want to thank everybody
for
acting
civilly
in our committee and i think we have the
most
bipartisan committee there is
and
what pleased me the most
is that when we can when we did the
revenues how we did it
and then both represent army and i could
stand up
together
and present him to the full house
and that really shows how we work
together we don't
i mean we can be republicans we can be
democrats and we can vote
our principles
but we can still
respect each other and we have done that
and so
what more can somebody ask for
so i hope everybody has a
good rest of the year
i know i have a couple more dedicated
fun
committees to go to i'm going to miss
this
and uh
it's been a pleasure working with all of
yeah so
yes if at the party we're gonna we're
gonna spend uh i guess after we eat
we're going to have a
time to talk
about norm your chance to say your
then we're going to spend a little time
remembering mary as well
and then uh remembering all those that
we know members here that have already
said they are not going to run again or
running for the senate
and we want to
give you a chance to say goodbyes if
you'd like
okay so that's what that's what we
haven't planned for
later
you'll probably start getting there by a
quarter two
uh and it'll take about ten minutes
it's if you basically go down north
north main street and keep on going
that intersection
so
oh the red blazer 72 manchester street
so if you're heading to the
it's the road heading out to where
lottery is if you've ever been out to
the lottery building
yeah he would go to main street and
change his under after he come out
underneath the the highway there the
innocent under 93 it changed his name to
manchester street from nothing
and it's on the right
it'll be on the right once you get down
there
huh
i don't know what hell you're talking
about
you're right you pass common man you go
don't think they will well they didn't
have enough votes against me on the
republican side i don't know who voted
for me and who voted against me on the
republican side but there were 20
27 write-ins
oh really well yeah and a lot of them
were in the wards where i